hi guys welcome to lesson three in this
lesson we're going to be learning about
building AI agents for construction with
no code tools meaning you don't need to
know any programming you don't need to
know any python to actually be able to
build some AI Tools in this lesson what
I'm going to start with is a quick
introduction about what AI agents really
are building upon some of the stuff we
learned in the last lesson and then
we're going to get our hands dirty we're
going to actually start code uh start
building uh
in real time so you're going to be
invited to join in and uh work alongside
uh me while I'm building some of these
tools so hope you're looking forward to
this one let's get started so what we're
going to learn in this lesson is we're
going to first look at what really are
AI agents what do we mean by this uh how
do we build these AI agents what they
can be used for and I want to
demonstrate how powerful they are um
this is going to set us up to actually
start doing the first practical so we're
going to be getting our hands dirty
building some of these AI tools um we're
going to be doing this with no code no
code tools um so you don't need to use
any python any coding uh anyone can do
this basically uh so we're going to
build one no code tool for analyzing
construction contracts this is going to
take a PDF Construction contract it's
going to analyze all the Clauses and
it's going to find some problematic
potentially problematic Clauses and flag
those up to you in a table summarizing
what the potential risk is with that
Clause what page it's on and what kind
of like severity of how unfavorable that
Clause is it's then also going to draft
a um renegotiation email so a first
draft of that which you can use to
potentially organize a meeting and to
highlight which uh Clauses you'd like to
discuss more
around so we're going to show you how to
actually create a repeatable automated
workflow so you don't need to do the
same prompting every time you
essentially
can upload a document and just have that
run automatically uh not need to
constantly repeat yourself um and we are
then going to show you how to build
something more advanced so we're going
to take uh site inspection photos and
turn those into a draft word report so a
draft inspection report from a bunch of
photos um which can be downloaded and it
will be the first draft of any uh things
that are spotted in the photo
summarizing them and like any risks or
hazards that have been spotted as well
so uh these are the three tools we're
going to build we're also going to show
you how to make full use of your civil's
AI license which comes with this
training so we're going to show you how
to use some of the AI agents we've also
been building um and help you get the
full use of your license that you have
so without further Ado let's get started
with the um summary of what AI agents
are so introducing AI agents
essentially AI has evolved very rapidly
as we saw in the past uh presentation in
the last lesson and with it we've had
this um more recent creation of this
concept of AI agents but what really are
they so these are essentially um some
higher level extra extrapolation on top
of um the AI models we were looking at
yesterday or in our last lesson and what
these can essentially do is with limited
uh human intervention they can actually
perform or automate some different tasks
they can do things like virtual customer
service Gathering data they can actually
work um in a similar way to what we as a
as humans could almost work like in
terms of knowledge work or data
preparation the key to these AI agents
is that we don't need to fully manage
them or maintain them they can work
without human intervention and generate
results let's dive into this a little
bit more so what we talked about last uh
in the last lesson very briefly was
around Transformer models and I
explained how trat GPT um on built on
top of other Technologies but one of
them is actually Transformer models so
what really are Transformer
models Transformer models are
essentially a form of neural network
which learns context and essentially
meaning when it learns enough context
for tracking relationships in sequential
data so a very easy example for you to
understand if I say the numbers one two
what comes next you're probably going to
say three this is essentially how
transform models work they just predict
the most likely next word uh letter or
in the sense of Transformer models you
usually say token so they predict tokens
so in this diagram you see here you see
the sky is you pass the
um sentence or set of tokens into a
large language model for example which
is a form of Transformer model uh it
then generates very quickly usually very
quickly um a likelihood of what the next
token would be and then it gives it a
score so here you can say blue has a
certain score clear has a certain score
usually and what it does is it scores to
try and find the most likely so here you
see the sky is blue is the most likely
and it therefore returns out the sky is
blue as the completed like uh
sentence it does this again and again to
try and predict until it reaches some
form of limit or some sort of concluding
um concluding token so here what we
basically see is that um is to do with
scoring likelihood based on the training
data that is already observed so it must
have seen in this case the sky is blue
the most in all of its training data for
it to believe that is the next um the
next token where we see and have
highlighted here in in bold and meaning
so the idea here is that if you train
with enough data if you have enough of
these tokens that have been trained on
these large language models can start to
display something more than just
predicting the next token they can start
to un people believe they can start to
understand the kind of meaning the
deeper meaning of what we as humans are
really trying to communicate when we
speak so um that's Up For Debate but uh
there's also some aspect of
understanding meaning and reasoning as
well so some of these foundational
models you will have probably heard of
uh which are Transformer models GPT
obviously I think is one of the most
famous ones but from Google Llama 2
which is quite an interesting one
because it's open source and also mistol
is open source so there's a bit of a
let's say war going on between um open
source versus closed source and no one
really knows which is going to win in
the long run which is going to be like
the more powerful models but right now
it's about TI tide um at the time of
writing this although you know open AI
are always um doing some interesting
stuff the important thing here is to say
it's not just limited to large language
models so when people talk think about
these Transformer models they could be
tempted to just think about large
language models but actually there are
other types of Transformer models that
are being used some for geospatial NASA
recently or last year released um a
Transformer model which is more for
geospatial analysis so it's not just
large language models um but these are
the most popular or the most wellknown
at this moment in time also just to to
talk uh more about this um in these no
with these no code examples everything
we're going to be doing is using large
language models though uh we're not
going to be using any other types of
Transformer models in this practical
lesson
so AI agents can essentially be built by
abstracting upon foundational models so
we have Transformer models it's this
lower level technology and then AI
agents are essentially this higher level
uh projection we build on top of that so
if you imagine in the sense of
programming you have something like some
Assembly Language or binary but we as
humans don't code uh on that level
because it's very hard to code on that
level it's very complicated and timec
consuming so we code on like a higher
level like python or for example which
is perhaps slower or less efficient but
it's much easier for us to uh work with
so transform model um AI agents are
essentially a higher level abstraction
which makes us makes it easier to build
with Transformer model
technology so let's take a look at one
such example of a AI agent configuration
so this is one of the more common ones
common ones where you essentially have a
commander um and let's say a writer and
a safeguard agent user asks a question
it can then ping or essentially ask
other AI um other Transformer models
within this Arrangement questions
receive back code receive back answers
and use it as a form of self-checking so
the idea here is that AI agents are able
to perform autonomous actions to meet
objectives without the need of us
constantly needing to check they can
kind of selfcheck and self-regulate in
to whatever they return back to the user
eventually is enhanced or better or more
accurate the concept here is that these
AI agents can actually learn you can
have memory associ memory storage with
these AI agents so that they can learn
they can make better decisions uh with
time and maximize the the key thing here
is maximizing their chances of achieving
that goal over just working with like
one Transformer model let's say
and these can be chained together to
create AI workflows so rather than just
using one uh transforma model you're
kind of stringing them together to
create a flow of information and arrive
at some end
result so AI agents yeah again like I
was saying are some form of Transformer
model in this in this
lesson let's take a look at one of the
more simple AI agent configurations to
understand this more closely so this is
one called the user proxy agent and
assistant agent the user proxy agent
here essentially works as a
representative of the user where this
user proxy agent can represent the user
and also execute some python codes so
the assistant agent you could think of
it as basically being um your chat GPT
it's essentially just going to be like a
Search tool um can return information uh
and knowledge to this user proxy
agent an example of um how these two
could work together so the user
themselves prompts uh this AI agencing
plot a chart of the meta Tesla stock
price um so this user sorry the
assistant agent is then going to say
execute this following code is going to
return this code back to the user proxy
agent who's then going to try and
execute it without the without the human
intervention is going to just try and
execute it and see what happens so here
it it tries to do that and it says okay
I don't have this python package
uh this python Library a requirement um
installed so this uh assistant agent is
going to say sorry please can you
install this first um in order to then
and then try and execute the code this
user proxy agent is then going to
install this Library try and execute the
code again and it's now successful at
this point that results returned back to
the user the user can see it and then
they say no please plot the percentage
change instead of this um sort of value
uh representation so it's saying here
okay got it here's the Revis code and it
executes it again so the the concept
here is that they work together to um
minimize or eliminate one task that the
user might have had to do themselves so
this is more efficient or it's more um
automated than it would have been
previously so the concept here is one
agent's checking the output um in order
to actually improve the accuracy and the
reliability of completing the user
objective
and um yeah so the the key thing here is
if you didn't have the user proxy agent
that would just have to come back to the
user they'd have to do it themselves
they'd have to do this execution of the
code themselves so we're eliminating
that task
here there are however multiple
different AI agent configurations we can
use which are better suited to some
tasks than others you can have math
solving you could have uh multi-agent
coding so that's the idea there is that
perhaps you have another uh AI uh or
Transformer model that's kind of like
checking the the code that's being sent
back to the user proxy agent or this
Commander agent is actually correct or
it's like bug free so you're getting
like a second check so these could all
be different configurations um which are
suitable for different use
cases let's take a look at why these are
so powerful right um so this is going to
build a lot on the last lesson where we
looked at AI model training and I was
saying how expensive this can be and how
complicated so what we're going to see
here is the real like true power of AI
agents as far as I we use them at
civil's Ai and how I see it so let's
look at this AI solvable problem you
have a photograph here of two people who
are working on a construction project
they're not wearing helmets right so um
you know health and safety they should
be wearing helmets when they're working
let's say on a construction site so we
want to create some model that can tell
us when there's like safety hazards on
the site like tell us when there's
people not wearing safety helmets let's
say we want to connect this into the
site CCTV and like automate all the site
safety supervision which is you know
some startups are doing this very cool
so let's say we want to try and solve
this right the traditional way of
solving this would be let's get a big
data set of all of these different
people wearing helmets different angles
different styles colors uh lighting
conditions we need as much data as we
can of people wearing helmets we also
probably want some of people like not
wearing helmets as well and uh you know
we want lots and lots of data basically
then with this data we want to label
every time there are helmets in the in
the photo we want to do data labeling we
want to do the bounding boxes and
identify all of those so we might need
thousands of these
photos um then we want to use a uh a
training some some form of AI model
training um so in this case we're
talking about YOLO which is like a
convolutional neural network an open
source one so in this case you could
actually use YOLO to do uh to create an
um convolutional neuron Network for
recognizing object detection of these
photos we can then upload some of our
photos so in this case it's some people
not wearing helmets although it doesn't
look like they're on a construction site
um and in this case we can label we can
identify that straight away okay
someone's not wearing a helmet in this
one and it will add to that if we have
enough data if we have enough training
data we've gone through that cycle a few
times potentially spent like a quite a
bit of money on this training we'll
eventually have our AI model that can do
this now let's look at the AI agent
approach AI agents don't need any of
that training data themselves um in
theory uh so um basically what we can do
is take the photo this end photo of um
whoever's not wearing helmets or
whatever the stream of information is
that's coming in we can take that and we
can actually convert that into uh binary
data so we can turn that into a string
of all the data of that represents that
photo we can then feed that into one of
the large language models um that's a
multimodal uh multim modal Transformer
model multimodal meaning that it can
read images alongside text it can read
like multiple different formats it's not
just text we can feed that into one of
these there's several uh examples gp4
Vision llama is another one and
essentially what we can do is um tell
that to return us the coordinates of a
bounding box which is around someone
who's not wearing a helmet or however
many people are not wearing helmets so
what we can do is create the
rectangle um the points of the rectangle
we can then feed that into another agent
a coding agent which will actually be
able to write us some code to turn the
points into a labeled uh box on the
photo so we can take the original photo
copy it let's say and then use the
coding agent to actually draw the Box on
the uh image itself the commander agent
can then execute this code and add that
box to the image the end result would be
the same let's say as what we had from
this traditional convolutional neuron
Network approach we have our labeled
image which has detected that someone's
not wearing a helmet so the difference
here being we didn't need all of the
training data we can use the
foundational model um with an AI agent
built on top to complete this task fully
without needing to go out and gather
data so if you imagine in construction a
lot of the time there is data privacy
issues there is like not that much data
available for you to be able to go and
train an aiel an AI model and Ai moding
and completely means that we don't need
all of the training data necessarily we
can actually build these AI Solutions
without needing to go out there and like
structure everything and spend lots of
money doing our training so this is the
real power of AI agents and we're going
to show you how you can start building
these uh right now okay so let's get
started with creating these AI agents
these no code AI agents for construction
so what I want you to do is go to the
notion page for the course I want you to
go down to lesson three and I want you
to open the cheat sheet that we have and
then when you to scroll down past the
presentation we were just giving and I
want you to find this section for
Construction contract reviews using
large language models the large language
model we're going to be using for this
uh experiment is going to be GPT 4 or
GPT 4 o um at the time of producing this
training these are the two latest models
and uh from Ai and what I'd like you to
do is make sure you have the premium
version of chat GPT but just make sure
you're using uh
40 so um what I want you to do here is
download this sample Construction
contract this is going to be the one
where we're going to first demonstrate
how this tool can work how AI agents can
work so what I want you to do is I want
you to get that PDF you can have a look
at it yourself you can see here it's a
sample it's a PDF for a sample
Construction contract it's onized
there's no information here just it's uh
you're told that this is in Colorado so
in the US and um here you have different
terms different uh Clauses explaining
how this contract is actually
administered um and you know reading
through this can be quite challenging
especially trying to understand what
these terms mean so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to take this PDF and
I'm actually just going to drag it into
chat GPT so I'm going to give it here
some context you can actually provide
files and data into chat GPT so what I'm
doing here is I'm providing it with this
PDF and what I want you to then do is
essentially provide a set of these
different prompts one by one so first
I'm going to ask this uh I'm going to
copy across step one which is
essentially asking um chat GPT the large
language model consider the law in
Colorado and the general best practice
for managing Construction contract risk
highlight the highest risk cles inside
this contract from the contractor
perspective so I'm going to start with
let's say a perhaps easier um challenge
for this to uh process so what you're
going to see here is it's going to just
start listing out um these different
Clauses which may have issues so you see
here it's a kind of like massive data um
it's bit it's a little bit unstructured
let's say um but here it's if if you
read these step by step you'll see that
it's flagging up um CLA CES or articles
in this case which potentially could
cause this um this user or whoever's
whoever's interested in signing this
contract it could cause them some
problems but what I want to do here is I
actually want to structure this some
more so I can actually say let's create
a table with this data so with that
previous data I want to um create a
table here of uh columns being risk type
risk description risk severity article
number page number and what you'll see
here is some AI agent functionality
starts so you click here analyzing you
see it's actually executing some code so
it's starting to create a table for us
and writing into each one of the rows of
the table um or each field is writing
that information in so it's actually
using some I guess py yeah python so
it's using python here to actually you
can see which language it's using here
to actually write out this table for us
um and perform the task so if I close
this now this is kind of like a view on
what the what the AI is actually doing
if I close this now you'll see here I've
actually got a table created which is um
which is exactly what I wanted so it's
saying here the risk type it's
describing what the issue is with that
risk um here so I can actually highlight
this um and see exactly what the what
the what what's being said here so
payment based on unit prices and actual
measured quantities can propose
Financial Risk um if actual quantities
differ from the estimates so obviously
yet payment variability uh clause in
there saying that this is relatively
high risk and it's saying the article
number and the page number so if I'm
actually back in the document I can
verify this myself so I can take a
shortcut and go across to where this
information is actually come from
wherever it is in page page two and um
verify this so the concept here is I can
cut through cut through the document and
basically summarize some of the risks in
there but this might not be enough for
what I actually want to do so in this
case I don't just want it to do this
task but I actually want it to also then
create a draft response letter which is
outlining some um let's say
some issues I might want to take up with
whoever's written this contract some
problems I might have so I also wanted
to IGN or any terms which could be
non-negotiable like compliance with
local laws there's no way you're going
to be able to sort of negotiate that so
I'm also going to say tell it to remove
anything that's not you know not going
to be
negotiable uh and what we have here is
this letter this draft letter being uh
created so here it's um you know quite
nicely written for a first draft it
sounds like I could have written it
myself and here it's highlighting each
article where there's a potentially like
some calls for concern and saying that
I'd like to take this up with you and
perhaps like have a meeting to discuss
this what my concern is so payment based
on unit prices and actual uh measured
quantities and saying here that um this
could POS some Financial Risk suggestion
that we propose um establishing minimum
payment guarantee based on estimated
quantities to mitigate Financial risks
so you see here it's basically um giving
me some very useful suggestions on what
could be uh prob s or what could be
perhaps more reasonable and more
favorable to me and obviously I need to
review this myself I should never just
trust whatever's coming back to me here
but this is really helpful in terms of
cutting out some of the noise so let me
let me highlight a problem with this
though as you've seen I've had to do
three different prompts to get to this
final uh answer of what I want so I've
had to prompt it three times with these
you know copy and paste it um this copy
pasted text but let's say I want other
people I want to I want to make this a
repeatable workflow that other people in
my team can perhaps um perhaps do and
they don't need to copy and paste these
these prompts how can I do that so I
want to standardize this flow and I
don't want to always have to
repetitively ask these questions so what
we can actually do here so one of the
things I like the most about chat GPT is
that they're actually doing some real AI
agent work now it's not just like a CH a
chat bot it's actually like fullon AI
agent uh development so if I click over
on this like open sidebar uh if you have
the premium version open you can click
explore gpts so the concept here of what
these gpts are is people can essentially
add some instructions some memory let's
say to um one certain version of g chat
GPT so what you have is like let's say
the standard chat bot and then you have
some memory or some instructions that it
has in mind so when you first interact
with it it's going to have some
additional data that it considers or
some instructions that are already there
so this is going to help us to create
some repeatable workflows so what I want
you to do is when you're on this page
you'll see a bunch that people have
already created they have now a kind of
store for all of these um some of them
are quite popular but what I want you to
do is actually create your own so in the
top right you can click create once
you've clicked this you're actually
going to be able to provide instructions
and create your own basic uh AI agent a
very generalized AI agent let's say but
for um but with your own instructions
you can customize this however you wish
I think usually by default it will
actually be on create here so you're
going to be able to do it with text but
actually what I want you to do is Click
configure and this is going to be a bit
more um tightly tightly controlled so um
if you if you use this it will be like
track gpt's guessing really what you
want to build whereas configure is going
to be you explicitly saying what you
want this AI agent to do and from here I
want you to go back to the notion page
and I want you to follow some of these
instructions in terms of creating this
custom GPT so here are the steps um and
I want you to basically take it from
here click configure on the left hand
column and from the left hand column I
want you to
basically um first copy so you can copy
this description in it's basically
explaining that this GPT takes a
Construction contract finds and scores
any risky Clauses and creates a draft
letter to negotiate any risky Clauses so
it's pretty simple instructions actually
but this let's see how this works I want
you to give it a name you can call it
anything you really want let's call call
it construction I'm going to call it
Construction contract
negotiator um and then here instructions
I want you to okay give it a bit more
detail in the instructions so what I've
put down here is a few different steps
I'm saying this GPT should take an
update an uploaded contract and consider
the law in okay Colorado but you can you
can put this wherever you you want I'm
just taking this example because this is
where um the contract ice that we're
looking at uh and general best practice
for managing Construction contract risk
find the highest risk Clauses create a
table summarizing these risks in the
table include as the columns the types
that we had before um after you finish
writing the table uh ask if I would like
to also generate the renegotiate
renegotiation letter if I say I want
this then write the letter outlining my
the concerns with the terms uh and with
suggestions over fairer terms which uh
we'd like to discuss further ignore any
terms which are negotiable so basically
I'm going to take this and I'm going to
copy it into instructions and these are
going to be my instructions for the AI
agent to follow you might need to just
clear up some of this formatting from
notion um conversation starters so this
could be um this is basically just what
uh you might want a button to show up
here which um you know the user can
press so um you know you might want to
say this like upload a
Construction
contract so um yeah you you could you
could have this as just a reminder of
what they're supposed to do but this
would actually be sometimes a question
to get things started uh knowledge base
so we're not actually going to use this
but you could upload some custom data
let's say which could be from perhaps
some guidance papers or some other
knowledge source that you want uh this
GPT to compare against and then in terms
of
capabilities I think it doesn't really
need web browsing it definitely doesn't
need this image
generation code interpreter um this
could be useful let's just include it
why not um but basically this allows you
to run code when the files have been
uploaded but I think we probably don't
need it too much unless someone uploads
a very hard to read some kind of hardto
read
PDF but in that case probably this
wouldn't work anyway if it's a very
complicated PDF so here you can also uh
add a logo if you want and this logo
will show up here but I'm not going to
do that in this case um just going to
now hit
create so I can now sh I can now set
this GPT up to be sharable so basically
anyone with a link can actually access
this so this is the concept of making
this a repeatable workflow I can share
this link with other people in the team
they can then use this tool and it kind
of standardizes that process so the
concept here is some sharing and
collaboration so I'm going to click save
I'm going to allow anyone to to see this
so but I'm not going to put it in the
store I don't really see the point of um
kind sort of publicly listing it and now
it's ready so let's test this out so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to um
let me just click this button right
upload a Construction contract so so uh
it's going to tell me please upload the
file so I can review it and identify the
highest risk Clauses so seems to be
working let me um add this PDF so it's
going to take a little bit of time to
process and let me send this off and
let's see what it does so here I've sent
it and it's generating me the table
yay and again it's doing exactly what I
wanted it to it's saying what the risk
description is um you know the the owner
has broad rights to terminate the
contract for defaults with potentially
high costs to the contractor all these
different risks right it's like churning
them out for me giving me some useful
information and then at the end most
importantly you know it's saying here
would you like me to also draft the
renegotiation letter outlining these
concerns and suggesting fairer terms for
discussion here I can just say yes so if
you imagine this was shared with someone
in the team they are literally getting
uh g chat GPT to prompt to them of what
they might want to do next so here's the
draft of the re renegotiation letter um
basically saying exactly why I want it
to again on which articles which pages
and what I'd like to discuss with them
okay next what I want us to do is to
create an AI for taking photos that have
been taken on the construction site and
turning that into a draft inspection
report which we can then download as a
word file so what I want you to do is go
back to the not page and I want you to
scroll down a little bit more to the
right section for site survey photos to
construction report and I want you to
download these sample photos just so
you've got some photos that we can use
for the
prompting uh then I want you to go back
to chat GPT and I want you to basically
get those photos um and I want you to um
drag and drop them into um into the
window so I've got these two photos here
I'm going to add them and then for the
prompting I want you to write out um
write up a summary of the seaw wall in
this
photo create a section for each photo
and for each section should include some
general description of the photo and
then a table with the following colums
risk description risk severity so um it
sometimes helps to actually give some
form of context so saying what roughly
is in the photos or what you expect to
see in the in these photos it really
helps it with um the identification so
what it's going to do here is it's
actually going to take these photos it's
going to turn them into binary data it's
going to use one of the multimodal AI
agent uh AI agents which um or AI models
which actually turn read the pixels
essentially uh read the pixel data into
a large language model and um return us
back some information so it identifies
what's actually contained in each pixel
itself
really quite amazing so what it's done
here is it's identified um it's okay the
first photo is a well-maintained sea
wall on a Sandy Beach the seaw wall is
constructed with large large concrete
sections that have curves designed
likely to help dissipate wave energy the
wall appears to be in good condition
with no visible signs of damage or
erosion so I would say this has very
well understood what this is a photo of
um and been able to tell us the risk
severity so it's basically saying like
kind of low risk I would probably agree
with that in my civil engineering
opinion that this is looks like quite
good condition so it's done a good job
here done a good job at understanding
that photo okay second photo is I would
say a much more uh worse worse uh
condition seaw wall in this case or
maybe not even seaw wall but some sort
of uh Marine structure and so with this
here um okay so it's identified it's
deteriorating along the Waterfront the
concrete is cracked and damaged exposed
rebars showing signs of corrosion is
this correct yes definitely so really
understood this image very well I would
say
um this area might not be directly
exposed to wave action but it's
suffering from structural weakness so
it's even understood that it doesn't
look like this is being damaged by the
Sea which I would probably also agree
with so um really amazing so understood
the photos very well
now let me um actually give it another
prompt so what I want this to do is not
just to understand the photos but I want
this to create a draft word report as
well so I want to take this information
that we've got here rather than me
copying and pasting it into a document I
want to actually write this into a Word
file automatically so you'll see here
it's analyzing once again it's using
Python and it's using docx which is
going to be a library we'll be using in
the next uh class or the class after
that so this is a python Library so it
automatically knows it needs this which
is quite amazing as well um and now it's
executing code to create a uh document a
Word document so here you see it's
adding headings it's basically um
describing F adding the photos um
creating tables you see here adding the
second heading um creating another table
so really quite amazing here
and then it's generated me once it's
executed this code it's now generated me
the link to actually uh run this um or
to basically download this file so here
I can see I've downloaded my um Sewall
analysis file so it's given a nice name
there and let's see what's inside so
here we see sew wall analysis so the
word um the word file so it seems to
have written written this table out very
nicely for me as well exactly what I
wanted photo one photo 2 I could
probably even ask it to include the
photos itself in this uh word report but
I won't here but we could also get those
included so what I could do with this is
I could basically turn this again into
another custom
GPT and have this as my own uh site
inspection to draft
report um AI that I could use repeatedly
okay so let me now explain how you can
make the most out of your civil's AI
license and I'll explain exactly how we
use AI agents as well so firstly I would
like you to go over to app.
civil. I then want you to get signed in
with your account which you're
registered with once you've got through
I want you to create your first project
so this is really easy to do you just
click create my first project once this
is set up you're then able to start
uploading
uh any documents that you wish so I'd
suggest uploading things like building
codes to start with perhaps you could
upload some specifications or even some
project working files if that's okay on
your project you could start uploading
some of the live working data as well um
from this point on uh the processing
will start we'll start using um various
different AI agents to read tables to
read text to read um or even um drawing
information you're able to upload CAD
drawings as PDFs as well so we use
various different AI agents for
collecting this information once this
information has been collected all of
your files will turn uh green it will
take a few minutes each file once this
processing is done you're then able to
search through all of this information
answering questions completing tasks um
basically you've built um an archive a
smart archive for all of that your
project data
so the idea here is that you're then
able to share this with other people in
your team so you're able to invite other
people to your project um and share this
information with them and essentially
what we're saving here is your time in
needing to read through all of these
different working documents or building
codes you can simply type for the
requirement that you're looking for
we'll open up the document at the right
Clause showing you exactly where that
information is located so this is the
way to think of civil I today as being
more of a search and a verification tool
creating a smart archive for all your
project
data let me explain exactly how this
works though so what we do with civil's
AI is we use a method called retrieval
augmented generation this means that we
take all of the text all the information
that exists in these project documents
and we read it out we read it into
something that's known as a vector
database what vect a database is is it's
a mathematical representation of the
meaning or the yeah the semantic meaning
of the words themselves once this
information has been read out and it's
in the vector database format your
queries are then compared in similarity
to the like the likeness of the uh the
data which is already in the vector
database and then what happens is you
use a method called Co science
similarity uh search and each uh each
term is scored and the most similar
terms are returned we then use a large
language model so we use GPT 4 to
actually do a comparison between uh the
extracted word and the word which uh the
query which you've submitted and we
attempt to try to answer that query or
perform that task for you if that's
unsuccessful we sometimes do a second
query we continue searching and that's
kind of our secret source so I'm not
going to go into too much information on
exactly how that works so in this lesson
you've seen how you can actually use no
code tools to start developing your own
AI uh We've shown how you how simple
this can be even using chat GPT and also
civil's AI so you don't need to know
coding to actually start implementing AI
on your construction projects and I hope
in this lesson we've given you the
confidence to be able to do that and to
start also experimenting for yourself so
as the final project if you're not so
confident in coding and the the
following lessons are not so um
appealing to you let's say perhaps as
your final project you just like to
create one of the custom gpts um and
submit that as your final project so
what I want to say here is that the next
sections of the course will be focused
more on beginners python so I'm going to
explain in the next lesson some the
scripts codes data structures that are
used in Python we're then going to use a
library called streamlit which is going
to allow us to develop web applications
with very little code all all it needs
is a little bit of python for us to be
able to start developing AI tools um
similar to the chat GPT versions We were
just looking at but actually much more
customizable and much more intuitive in
some ways so that's what we're going to
be doing in the next couple of lessons
so if you're not so interested in coding
perhaps you'd like to think more about
how you'd like to work with one of the
custom gpts instead so in the next
lesson we're going to really jump into
python development and we're going to
I'm going to give you a beginner intro
into applying python on construction
projects and start to give you the
building box for building your own AI
Solutions